oh i see you did a whole new intro for
season eight is it still over 60 seconds
sin also this damn show single-handedly
encouraged so many other shows to draw
out their introduction with fancy
visuals but why go through the trouble
of creating a map when you're going to
depict king's landing without blackwater
rush running alongside it four bowing
bow shadowing this child is running
through a snowy forest and over an icy
stream with no mittens no wool hat and
no boots with the fur did no one warn
him that winter was coming running
between people when running around them
is clearly an option no no don't climb
things when you're a child in this show
you'll be booted to your doom by a sex
crazed sibling or geeded by a yeti or
iced by an oversized iguana this
glancing between people goes on for all
the some time and the only thing we gain
from it is a reminder of arya's feelings
feelings northerners don't watch trust
outsiders
i get that dragons often have amazing
dramatic timing it's like in their
character sheet and everything but the
question is how did they even hear this
conversation from that far away to know
when to swoop in we already saw this in
the two minute long opening credits show
just because you have dragons now
doesn't mean you get to go all throne
drone on your cinematography also this
doesn't look anything like the shot in
the opening credits sure the shape's
mostly correct but the building
placement is all wrong and i don't even
see any of the letters of winterfell
written in the snow anywhere we don't
have time for all this
thank you bran i've been trying to say
this there's only six episodes left to
wrap up the entire story let's get smart
someone should make that boy the king
[Laughter]
king bran as if the night king has your
dragon he's one of them now if the night
king can turn animals why hasn't he
created an army of former wolverines
bears and mooses musai musa pusses it's
not important i agree so honor the
battles and dragons and betrayals and
twists not yet fine must be saving this
episode's big battle for the middle huh
we named you king in the north
[Applause]
you know the beer commercial where
someone would start a what's up chain it
was so frustrating because you'd be
sitting at dinner and someone would
whisper what's up and then you'd
reflexively just jut your tongue out and
spout out what's up like a caveman i'm
just saying that channing king of the
north is the game of thrones version of
that viral audio std chanting i hate it
i chose the north okay but can someone
tell me what the noth is seems important
they keep on saying it and soon the
lannister army will
ride north to join our cause thinking
that tyrion would actually believe this
for even a second and yes sansa calls
him out on it later but that doesn't
change the fact that i'm super sad that
tyrion is apparently gullible and dumb
now what do dragons eat anyway whatever
they want this is literally one of the
oldest jokes in the book i mean sure it
was originally written about where a
500-pound gorilla would sleep but the
punchline was the same my point is that
this joke flew in from the distant past
and boy are its arms tired last time we
spoke was at joffrey's wedding miserable
affair it had its moments
okay now that was funny staring staring
staring staring
excitement how did you sneak up on me
how did you survive a knife through the
heart people who answer questions with
unrelated questions also the show fails
to remind the audience of how
resurrected people in bloody tear trees
make any damn bit of sense if you've
used it asking a woman if she knows how
to use a needle sansa thinks she's
smarter than everyone she's the smartest
person i've ever met sansa i mean she
did let littlefinger convince her to
turn away brianna's to protect her so
maybe let's not be so vehement about
putting her at the top of that list
twenty thousand men is it
yes your grace a few died in transit and
this episode is taking so much time on
drawn out conversations and political
maneuverings that it might as well have
been a star wars prequel but at least
we'll get to some dragons to death soon
not yet fine must be saving this
episode's big battle for the end huh
i've executed men for less
they were lesser men this works that boy
eddie
the ginger
that's him came back with his face burnt
right off talking about it sheeran's
melted skin during sexual intercourse
you know boring
i'll give you that thing not a single
person said to this episode of
television somehow makes its way into
the script probably the most confusing
part of this episode is the amount of
time it takes theon to cut his sister's
bonds with the weapon that split a head
open like a melon a moment ago
siblings they kill the bastards anyway
that's john snowist i sense that you're
leading to a proposal a proposal is what
i'm proposing and i made you follow my
lootings all the way up here because i
enjoy the sound of my own voice and
could not be bothered to express myself
down below because my fragile ego cannot
soar as it deservedly does up here john
and daenerys don't want to listen to
lonely old men seems he's skip what's up
with all these bones i would think the
dragons just ate their prey whole and
were able to digest the bones in the
fire of their belly or something what
goods of being a dragon if you still
have to pick the bones clean with your
paws and jaws then i've enjoyed your
company jon snow do you ever stop and
think of how on the nose and easy to
spell jon snow's name is because he's a
bastard i wish everyone's name were that
simple then i wouldn't have to google it
every time i mentioned his love interest
jane fire or their archenemy susie
incest jon snow is not impaled on a
dragon spine spike in this or the
following scene sweet jon snow and jane
fire gonna do full dragon warfare and
toast some fools oh it's just gonna be
some how to train your dragon joyride
montage isn't it also shouldn't she know
he's a targaryen since he survived
riding a dragon or is that just in the
book either way if i've said it once
i've said it a million times the books
matter can someone explain why both
daenerys and john look so warm and cozy
they've just had their faces blown
around by northern winds while atop
dragons mind you and their lips aren't
even chapped drogon doesn't say you're
[ __ ] your aunt in this scene isn't
easy making a blade that big with
dragonglass blowing smoke up someone's
axe here's my wish this weapon probably
turns out to be important but i'm gonna
go ahead and sin that she fails to give
any dimensional details is this thing
supposed to be long like a lance short
like a dagger itty-bitty like a hairpin
how is gendry supposed to interpret the
important details from this do you think
we can beat the army of the dead without
her thinking there's anyone strong
enough you could recruit to beat the
snyder bros i borrowed a few books from
the citadel grand theft reading
jump mirrors okay i've put this off long
enough last time john was here ned said
the next time we see each other we'll
talk about your mother i promise and now
the next time he's here sam will tell
him about his lineage payoffs like that
and several other echoes of season 1
throughout this episode are the reason
this show can deliver like no other and
i can't help but give another sin off i
had a high septon's diary bran had
whatever brown has oh it's nice to see
sam's put about as much thought into
explaining bran's gifts as the writers
of the show the younger boy yep that's
right instead of seeing any big white
walker battles we only get to see the
aftermath of one not that it looks like
it was much of a battle not exactly a
ringing endorsement for umber armor if
you ask me protect this house my ass
episode ends by having tom incest and
jake boredom engage in a staring contest
thank you for nothing you useless
reptile they even got a special map that
lets you choose who you want to dump
your poop on
[Music]
the first they heard was a noise like a
hurricane coming down from the north
the pines on the mountain creeped and
cracked in the hot dry wind look at you
your grounds up what do you think you're
doing
don't be afraid
[Music]
there's that command lady stark
don't call me that
as you wish milady that day she was
amazed to discover that when he was
saying as you wish
what he meant was i love you